كشف تحقيق استقصائي نجره الاتحاد الدولي
للمحققين الصحفيين ان مجموعه اسرائيليه
متخصصه تقوم بنشر الفوضى في العالم
وتدخلت في عشرات العمليات الانتخابيه في
انحاء العالم وذكرت صحيفه الجارديان
التحقيق تضمن لقطات سريه
ووثائق طلعت عليها الصحيفه تشير لان
الفريق الاسرائيلي يديره عنصر سابق في
القوات الخاصه الاسرائيليه ويعمل تحت اسم
المستعار هو خورخي ويحترف عمليات التلاعب
السريه بالانتخابات في بلدان مختلفه لاكثر
من عقدين من الزمن يكشف التحقيق ان خورقي
قدم خدماته لوكالات استخبارات وحملات
الانتخابيه سياسيه وشركات خاصه استعانت به
للتلاعب بالراي العام سرا
وشملت قائمه عملائه زبائنا من جميع انحاء
افريقيا وامريكا الجنوبيه والموسطى
والولايات
واوروبا